freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge oder ist es eine neue folge
ein tag persönlich kommt auf jeden fall
werde ich heute bekocht von niemand
geringerem als eric eric vor der kamera
hinter der kamera als justus danke dass
du aus leer gekauft hatte für mich ich
habe mir ein paar rezepte gewünscht der
vorschlag kam aus der community und ich
werde es genießen heute weil dieser
kleine miese ist dem alter allererste
wenn eine kleinigkeit anstatt zu sagen
apple amazon macht lacht der anfang ich
dachte einfach so aus dem herz heraus in
der region so miami aufenthalt habe ich
mir ein breit gefächertes amerikanisches
frühstück gewünscht werden leckere los
ich werde den ganzen tag über einfach
ein paar gemüse kommentare bringen hier
von der seite ein bisschen abwarten dann
weiß ich
das ding ist besser hat das ganze so gut
harmonieren und es hier weil ich auch
sehr gerne kocht ist man also als
allererstes natürlich was haben wir hier
picks live baic so richtig ich habe
gesagt halben fingerdick geschnitten
bitte und das kommt jetzt alles als
allererstes in den backofen ich sehe das
jetzt einfach mal ganz ungeniert hat die
alle politik zu gestalten
genau das krieg ich helfe dir meinen
dass das feuer auf das wird hier aber
ich bin wirklich gespannt wie du auf ein
ende des tages zu diesem tempo aktiv weg
gelangen wird vielleicht müsste endlich
mal verstehen was hier eigentlich leiste
vor der kamera das ding ist ich habe ja
auch noch nie so richtig für dich
gekauft ja eigentlich ganz easy backofen
schon vorbereitet auf 200 grad ober
unterhitze und da waren es dass jetzt
schon für so 15 20 uhr wieder ein
schöner als nächstes wir haben nicht nur
bacon wir haben nicht nur pancakes wir
haben nicht nur square bild in der soft
version sondern macht sich auch noch
hedgefonds gewünscht genauer ganzen
anregung an das making practice von
george foreman ein meiner lieblings
köche und kann eigentlich nur lecker
sein aber da ist auch ein bisschen muss
jeder bei und was mir natürlich auch
gedacht habe ist natürlich auch einige
fehlerquellen das heute ganz lustig ich
habe wirklich ein stück weit in mir
gesehen hat nämlich ihre rezepte genannt
habe die pigs tier dann auch so
verschiedene bausteine zusammen und
entwickelt daraus soll ein eigenes
wir haben hier eine schüssel und
das ganze sieht die leute die sich
fragen was sind herrscht bei uns
überhaupt war das habe ich auch am
anfang erstmal ihr kennt sicherlich so
reibekuchen und am ende des tages sind
einfach reibekuchen nicht auf rheinische
art sondern amerikanischen auf hat keine
angst haben schaut ich bin da wirklich
viel salz rein ganze einmal schön
auswaschen und dann richtig schön
auspressen das ganze auch mal mit beiden
händen da mit liebe auch sehr wichtig
also wichtigste bordeaux bacon riechst
du ihn ja ja erstmals unvorbereitet
zweite hauptteil des frühstücks werden
pancakes seien dazu tun wir drei eier in
einer schüssel
diese drei jahre hier richtig bin
zu 200 milliliter joghurt 100 milliliter
milch vermischen wir jetzt in einer
schüssel nicht das ist ein bisschen
klein also nehme ich auf jeden fall eine
größere schiffe oder macht einfach einen
messbecher
unklar
hier haben wir noch mehr eine packung
backpulver zwei esslöffel zucker und
eine prise salz das muss jetzt einfach
nur nach und nach alles mit dazu gegeben
werden
und das wird jetzt so richtig schön die
flüssigen masse man merkt das auch schon
beim rühren genau so soll es sein das
hat jetzt das geile werde schon
vorbereitet der bacon ist nur schon
hinten und jetzt müssen wir nur noch
auspacken
[Musik]
vreni
wunderschönen besten nehme ich an noch
abend die rub drauf bisschen ahnung wir
uns drauf wir analysieren das mit dem
auge alles also ok gates in sehr schöner
haben eine schöne farbe früher als sehr
schönes oft auch vom ansehen her
eindeutig urteil dann haben wir hier den
cache brown wehrte auch präsentiert
fähig hinbekommen muss man auf jeden
fall sagen der bacon hier mit sirup hier
ohne diese rolle kenne ich gar nicht ihr
somit neben mir steht einer
erwartungsvoll qtom ihr erstes mal den
bacon
geschmacklich sehr sehr geil bisschen zu
gelangen sie hier natürlich ganz wichtig
in eschborn die größte ist wirklich
anders
man schiebt würde damit
[Musik]
die schon eigentlich sehr sehr leicht
sehr fix nicht noch mal probieren
ich glaube
wichtig für mich diese perspektive noch
mal kennenzulernen das bewerten ist gar
nicht mal so einfach denn case warst du
zu recht selbstbewusst wüsste nicht
welche kleider sind bei der milch oder
joghurt herr travelex die waren auch
perfekt bei beiden kann ich nichts sagen
folge war bacon die große schwachstelle
von ihrem teller einfach weil er so
lange lage ja es ist eine sache die man
lernen muss ja herr schön knusprig
schöne konsistenz bisschen stark
gesalzen fand ich persönlich ok 8,5
punkte kriegst du von mir okay ja also
das wissen wir das wird aber das ist gut
beim mittagessen kann sie jetzt mehr gas
geben ich kühe 100 prozent und weiß auch
das ist kraftvoll neu verlegt derzeit
acht super gut aber ich weiß auch dass
mehr kannst deshalb freut sich aufs
mittagessen ich genieße es weiter und da
ist sie sogar überraschend von mir
deshalb sehen wir uns willkommen zum
mittagessen schaut euch an was wir hier
feiern das habe nicht liegt das messer
sofort wieder hinhält übergeben wieder
nicht was hast du die überlegt ich hab
dir einfach wie gesagt ich möchte gerne
eine leichte passte ganz genau und dann
hat mein kopf natürlich direkt
gearbeitet und das ist dabei
rausgekommen
eine tastatur mit frischen blattspinat
frischen knoblauch zwiebel etwas
zitronen abrieb cherrytomaten aus dem
backofen karamellisierten walnüssen und
[Musik]
leckerer berater aber die murata nur das
innere in verbindung mit etwas
abgelöscht dem weißwein und
mutig aber geil also es klingt sehr geil
na da ich bin gespannt ob also das ist
ein gericht was für mich im kopf einfach
schon so sinn macht so das ist einfach
das sind so dinge die einfach spaß
machen und als allererstes muss ich
nämlich die tomaten in den backofen
geben damit die so lange wie möglich das
schön durchziehen können ich weiß nicht
ob das schon mal gemacht habt aber wenn
ihr so strauchtomaten habt einfach
olivenöl salz und dann so richtig lange
backofen so 25 minuten dann kocht die so
in sich und krieg manchmal so ganz ganz
andere aromen das lieben wir werden so
grobes meersalz drüber und ab damit
das hundertwasser schnee bereitet schon
dass das abendessen vor als nächstes
habe ich mir so vorgestellt dass wir als
allererstes die walnüsse karamellisieren
also ein kleines stück butter
es muss jetzt auch gar nicht wirklich zu
karamellisieren aber die sollten nachher
so ihren geschmack mitbringen aber
gleichzeitig auch so eine kleine süße
damit sieg abbaurechte für euch anders
herum angezogen haben ja auch mein
gesicht ein bisschen mehr sehen könnt
sowie sehr leid junge grieche alter ist
mit save food also halbe lungenflügel
ich hasse es max planck zwiebelschneiden
zu filmen sagt jeder ruhig mal eure
meinung weil ich finds so unnötig das zu
sehen da finden hast du jetzt auch wenn
ihr mich beim team entstand film ist
sagt mal eure meinung ist unnötig oder
es ist nicht irgendein
olivenöl reinen klatschen gutes olivenöl
und rein mit dem zwiebeln frischer
knoblauch
so wenn die zwiebel im staat sein tun
wir ich bin hart rein
wer spielt verliert jetzt ordentlich an
volumen das werdet ihr jetzt gleich
sehen jetzt ist es soweit die spinat
felder sind richtig schön ineinander
reingefallen und das ist auch dann der
richtige zeit wo nichts ist ein bisschen
runter zu fahren und wie knoblauch
hinzuzufügen
das ganze jetzt schön vor sich hin und
das ist der moment wo wir ein bisschen
weißwein eingeben pinot grigio
an die angebote hin und wieder
als jamo
33 remote wake dort mit dem schiff
erkochen karten werden
teller pasta dsw danach kommen mag
wassermann so salzig sein wie das meer
und jetzt finde ich jetzt auch zeit
punkt angekommen wo wir das ganze jetzt
zum ersten mal auch würzen können gerne
so nicht haben
hmm spinatblätter habe ich jetzt
wirklich zu einer ganz niedrigen
temperatur gehabt gemacht hat eben waren
es noch knapp oberhalb einer niedrigen
temperatur gemacht in japan befinden
sich jetzt in niedrig die hat er aus dem
gewühl möglichkeit zum aufholen der
pasta benutze ich jetzt so eine schnelle
und two die passt direkt in die panne
rein weil ich hier so kriegt man so
perfekte menge an nudelwasser noch mit
in die soße rein so ordentlich zeit
schnell rüber sind auch nicht mehr
letzten nicht ab drauf man kann auch
diese marken können auf ein ziel das ist
auf jeden fall gleich dass die berater
zusammen mit dem olivenöl und den
tomaten so eine richtig schöne cremige
masse ergibt wenn wir jetzt hier bin ich
so sie ist weiß ich meinen deswegen dass
nudelwasser gleich auf jeden fall ganz
wichtig olivenöl und diplomatisch dann
heißt es nur noch anrichten so
gemacht
[Musik]
das können auch ganz kurz weisweil
einschränken die mussten wir das hier
aussieht auf dem teller alter ich danke
dir das könnte mich dass hübsches zu
sein was ich heute auf dem teller haben
werde was sehr sehr schön ist die
berater ist vielleicht an geschmolzen
und sie darum brauchen frischen pfeffer
kanalisierte walnüsse ofen tomaten
spinat und darunter die pasta rigatoni
natürlich auch eine sehr fotogen ehepaar
zagat bitte bevor du bist einmal
komplett durch mischen ok costa weil
alles muss miteinander verbunden werden
unten habe ich nämlich auch noch extra
flüssigkeit also müssen passt aber
soliden dann das blatt den tomaten und
so weiter erst wenn jetzt alles
verbunden als die berater etc
dann ist die pasta so wie sie eigentlich
gedacht ist wenn ihr mal hier auf den
teller schaut seht ihr auch dahin steht
auf jeden fall nochmal cremigkeit also
man könnte denken was ist das für eine
pasta sauce einfach nur spinat ein
bisschen aber ich tu dir jetzt den
gefallen es sie so wie sie konzipiert
ist packt alles auf einen löffel so ich
bin gespannt librettisten bisher nicht
probieren
das muss reichen das gleich wieder groß
auf also man könnte meinen dass sie
genau wie ich auch viel gelernt hast
darüber was ein gutes gericht aus machte
im letzten jahr weil wir haben relativ
wenige zutaten ist trotzdem richtig
geile akzente so dadurch dass ich alles
auf einem löffel probiert habe knusprige
und süße wein und cremige berater und
leichte säure von den tomaten und
wirklich eine cremige soßen körper mit
so einem frischen spinat so dass alles
komplimentiert die nudeln sehr sehr gut
und es ist eine geile kreation also
wirklich sehr sehr geil war das sehr gut
geschmeckt ich muss dir 95 von 10 geben
weil der garten von den nudeln für mich
persönlich nicht perfekt getroffen dort
werden nämlich was gesagt ich hab's
extra genauso gemacht also wenn ich
jetzt dadurch dass kassiere finde ich
das auch völlig fitte das kassieren das
ja auch viel gesagt wer weiß wie gut wir
gegessen haben und das ist wirklich eine
geile kreationen dafür dass du dir die
sponti überlegt hast wer sich jetzt noch
ganz ganz wenig luft nach oben ich bin
gespannt wo diese luft nach oben
ausreizen wird beim abendessen das crazy
weil wir haben das ganz ganz ganz
besonderes
wir haben jetzt 10 uhr 53 etwas später
als eigentlich gedacht wir verbreiten
jetzt schon das abendessen vorbei es
muss den ganzen tag köcheln damit es
genauso gut wird dass es mir gewünscht
dass ist genau richtig ich habe es mir
nicht leicht gemacht ich habe wirklich
ich glaube die ganze sache die ich im
letzten jahr gegessen habe mir von der
gewünschten zwar die akkus die wir in
miami gegessen habe und das ist schon
mal eine herausforderung überhaupt
darzustellen in deutschland beispiel
diese chilis wir liegen ja gar nicht
gleich zu bekommen also ganz am anfang
haben wir zwei hoch schritte eigentlich
erstens müssen die so solange also die
bilder soße an sich und das fleisch
müssen wir schon mal antraten die größte
errungenschaft
deswegen würde ich sagen müssen wir
jetzt als allererstes von den chilis die
kerne entfernen oben den stiel entfernen
auch ganz wichtig und dann wirklich nur
die reine chili ohne die kerne in den
topf reintun paar kern ist kein problem
alle chips sind jetzt entkernt und als
nächstes müssen wir ein paar tomaten
reintun da ganz grob einfach halbieren
auch so in den topf 1 weil da kommt
gleich einfach nur noch wasser rein und
das ganze bringen die zum kochen um das
ganze aufzuweichen und danach einem
mixer zu mal richtig geilen saucen
sondern bei mir ein schönes zungen stück
aus den nacken und
ochsenschwanz bevor wir unser fleisch
anbraten salzen wir es noch richtig
schön großzügig
ist gleich ist fleißig am warten und in
der zeit können wir schon mal unsere
gewürze malen dazu nehme ich hier
einfach so einen kleinen mixa die
lorbeerblätter tue ich noch beiseite die
sich für später aber wir haben hier eine
wunderschöne auswahl an verschiedensten
gewürzen oregano koriander pfeffer salz
der kreuzkümmel mail können all diese
wunderschönen gewürze kommen jetzt hier
rein
muss wirklich richtig schön fein sein
man sieht wie schön der boden sich
langsam los mit diesem trieben die
tomaten zwiebeln chili mischung ist
fertig man sieht schon richtig schön die
chilis sind jetzt einfach richtig schön
weich geworden sie sind biegsam geworden
genauso brauchen wir sie jetzt müssen
wir sie in den mixer reintun und
zusammen mit den tomaten
und etwas wasser aus dieser mischung
nicht alles aber erstmal nicht alles für
mich wir nehmen uns die chilis wie sich
auch das war's aperta
da kommt jetzt auch unsere
gewürzmischung rein sagt und ein
bisschen pause passte auch nur einen
kleinen löffel
das gleiche raus geholt damit wie die
zwiebeln rein tun können und somit den
boden lösen können das fleisch kommt mir
jetzt wieder rein und füllen dann den
topf mit dem fleisch mit unserer biglia
soße auf wir haben hier noch restliche
flüssigkeiten von unserer rinderbrühe
mit den chilis und das kommen jetzt auch
noch hier rein bei ist es ganz wichtig
dass wirklich das ganze fleisch bedeckt
nicht nur das kommt jetzt rein sondern
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen wasser
ihr habt gemerkt das war jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht so viel weil die
eigentliche zeit wird jetzt erst da rein
investiert das bleibt jetzt bis heute
abend bis zum abendessen genauso stehen
und wir tun die lage besser ein deckel
drauf und jetzt gibt es zwei optionen
entweder und lässt es die ganze zeit bei
niedriger hitze auf dem ceranfeld stehen
oder auf eine normale kopf fällt oder
tust es bei ungefähr 150 bis 170 grad
gebacken na ja klar
so holen dann sage ich hab einfach sechs
knoblauchzehen vergessen zu sie einfach
rein und hebt sie dann so ein bisschen
unter aber das musste ich einfach noch
machen weil also knoblauch ihr wisst
freude eric holt jetzt aus dem ofen
liberia soße in fleisch was jetzt drei
oder vier stunden gekocht das eigentlich
schon fast 1 5 stunden takko videos kann
man kann ein bisschen länger scratch
machen dass irgendwann mal jetzt ist nur
die frage wie schmeckt das ganze wie
sich das aussehen gucken da jetzt
gemeinsam rein leute oh
[Gelächter]
ja dieser fettfilm oben
wie hoch das stammt alles weitere ist
einfach so verkopft ich habe angst ich
stelle mir vor dass vielleicht ist jetzt
nicht zahlt höchstens ausnehmen das feld
eröffnung auseinanderfällt ich nehme es
nur mit der zeit
hätte damit gerechnet
so ist es ja so wie man sich das immer
würden klar wir müssen jetzt die tachos
vorbereiten wir müssen ein bisschen
zwiebelschneiden bisschen koriander
schneiden danach kommt alles auf die
gusseiserne platte auf dem grill schöne
an resten fleisch drauf bisschen
mozzarella dann muss man es probieren
[Musik]
schon langsam studio
abend ist die schwere schwieriger dieser
geruch täglich direkt nach miami und
schüler richtig sehnsucht nach miami
nicht zuletzt gegen den tacos man merkt
natürlich direkt schon das mit dem
kranich hat nächstenhilfe wo es ein
bisschen anders essen da welche rein in
die source und
scheiß auf die rede später du hast von
riehl den geschmack der geschmack auf
den kopf getroffen das ist genau der
text von durch die wieder wer wie
erkläre ich jetzt den leuten da draußen
wie das schmeckt für darf auch nicht es
erstmal auch leute werden auch ein
bisschen rumprobiert ich habe die erste
straße schon gegessen aber ihr seht
schon sie haben sich leicht bei in das
jahr sind wir uns leicht verändert
irgendeinen schritt meines das erste mal
zu bereiten ist nicht ganz richtig
gelaufen wir bräuchten quasi hätten so
ein extrakt zum öl gebraucht um die
dinge anzupacken es jetzt einfach nur in
anführungszeichen airbus irgendwann aber
es ist ja egal wie dick das hier rein
und dann hört sich das so an
der
neben anderen allein schon das feeling
wieder sich jetzt anfühlt knusprigen
meistert ihr unfassbar geschmackvoll ist
aus einnahmen teilen des fleischs ich
hatte sorge dass mozzarella nicht dem
mexikanischen von dort gerecht wird euch
höhere dafür dass du das für mich
erlebbar gemacht hast in deutschland
habe mich selbst immer darum gedrückt zu
machen ist und hättest du zehn partien
es ist einfach ein fest leute dann fürs
zuschauen da eric das für mich einen tag
dann gekocht hat das mich sehr sehr gut
gemacht war köstlich selbst die
steigerung auf acht und halb zehn wir
sind zwar nichts mit dem 8 bis dann job